[Music]  he warned us that something was coming  if there is ever an end in this forever  war it will be because of you and your  strong right hand where the line in the  sand we fight against the forces of  darkness this is the expecting a sign  that says secret headquarters oh I need  some ID love are you serious you made me  a damn weapon I just wanted to help you  become the best you  [Applause]  some dad's get their kids Legos save the  world of silence  does it do anything special yeah it  smashes things real good  [Music]  you are mankind's best and only hope  we were supposed to be fighting monsters  not working with  are you calling monster pal you looking  at me recently  I interrupt  these are just in time  [Music]  [Music]